[Music]
for this video i won't be including
anything from season 8 like the death of
the night king or john killing daenerys
because those moments are drenched in
plot holes
plot armor contrivances and overall bad
writing
if i were to include any best moments
from season 8 i'd rather pick something
like
brand becoming a knight or click gamble
given that they're at least
enjoyable but i'd rather just watch any
of my top 25 moments on repeat
to apply one ground rule for this
ranking i won't be bundling a bunch of
related moments together like arya and
tywin scenes
because i feel like that would be a bit
unfair towards scenes that are more
continuous
and as always this is my opinion number
25
viserion destroying the wall ah you know
what scratch that i'm making this an
honorable mention
this scene would be 10 times better if
dave and dan had not shown the night
king turning viserion at the end of
beyond the wall
it would actually give the ending of the
season a lot more shock and awe instead
of everyone just waiting for it to
happen
because of this it gives the whole scene
a much more predictable nature
it is visually spectacular but it's just
a moment where you go yep that was cool
and then move on since it doesn't add
much besides it being an extension to
their prior reveal
it's like if david and dan were to show
us a scene of tywin deliberating with
walder frey before the red wedding to
kill rob stark
that initial dialogue would be shocking
but it would ruin the big moment of the
red wedding
so instead of the syrian destroying the
wall i'd rather pick a scene with a lot
more valley to contribute which is
tywin's opening scene as number 25.
this is a pure unadulterated classic
tywin lannister scene
literally every line that he delivers in
the scene has gained a status as if they
were lines in the holy bible
a lion doesn't concern himself with the
opinions of the sheep
tywin lannister oozes wisdom with every
breath he takes
and his opening scene is by far one of
his best because he's not just lecturing
jaime
but he's also lecturing the audience
about how the lannisters
operate all of these lines are great and
the reason why i'm not putting this
higher on the list
is because this isn't a dialogue scene
that's injected with a lot of emotion
and that's not the fault of this scene
that's just me liking dialogue scenes
that have more of an emotional punch to
them
but as it stands though this is a
perfect introduction to not just taiwan
lannister
but to also house lannister and come on
skinning a deer while delivering a
monologue is so goddamn badass
number 24 oberyn martel declaring he'd
fight for tyrion
now for the scene i'm not just referring
to the twist reveal that oberyn will be
tyrion's champion
but also the long and juicy monologue
that oberyn delivers prior to the twist
i think this is a very heartbreaking
reveal that shows the prejudice that
cersei has always felt towards tyrion
through a more neutral perspective
this is shown when oberyn details his
interaction with what he believed at the
time
would be cersei unveiling a freak but in
actuality
it was just a normal baby when this
revelation happens
the music kicks in for a very sincere
moment
it doesn't matter she told us everyone
says he will die soon
i hope they are right this whole scene
is also heavily carried by the acting
pedro pasquel is a goddamn legend and
you'd be mistaken if one of his main
monologues
that ends with a triumphant punch
wouldn't be on this list
i really enjoy the irony of this scene
too a man who fundamentally hates
lannisters
ends up helping a lannister it's overall
very gratifying having the scene in a
season
where tyrion was essentially getting
dunked on by every character in the show
thank you oberyn i love you man i would
gladly take a spin off where we just go
on adventures with you
number 23 robert and cersei having a
conversation
at face value it may seem weird to be
putting the scene on the list given how
casual it is
but almost every line is so distinctly
quotable
we have cersei poking fun at robert and
ned's bromance i'm sorry your marriage
to ned stark didn't work out
robert's clever rebuttal to cersei's
strategic advice
it's a neat little trick you do you move
your lips and your father's voice
comes out foreshadowing for when the
dothraki eventually make it to westeros
witnessing how intellectual robert is
when he's not drunk out of his mind
a sincere look as to what went wrong
with their relationship
and the tragedy of what lust can do to a
man through robert's mention of
lyanna and seven kingdoms couldn't fill
the hole she left behind
the scene consistently offers so much
value in terms of character development
and even world building especially for
robert's rebellion
this whole scene is about 6 minutes long
and it breezes by
due to the sheer fact of how intriguing
the dialogue is
overall a shining example as to how
great dialogue scenes were in the
earlier seasons
number 22 chaos is a ladder
the classic iconic duo of intellectual
battles that is varys and littlefinger
there's quite a few scenes where they
hash it out but i think my favorite is
the one in season 3 where littlefinger
delivers one of his best monologues in
the show about
chaos the only reason why i'm putting
this scene a bit low on the list is that
it's kind of short
the scene lasts for about 4 minutes and
if it was longer we had more sparring
between varys and littlefinger
then i would definitely put it higher
but as the scene stands
varys and littlefinger have one round of
jabs until they start talking about the
realm which then leads into the chaos
monologue
it's still completely stellar and i
think aidan gillen who plays
littlefinger peaks here in terms of
acting
his voice and betrayal of littlefinger
is so chilling and
evil it really makes you think that his
character is destined for great things
but we know that's not the case
unfortunately
number 21 elena's death scene
this probably has to be single-handedly
the most badass death scene in the show
maybe besides leona mormont taking down
the giant but still
elena's revelation to jaime that she
killed joffrey is a perfect way to end
her character and this should go without
saying
but elena tyrell is one of the best
characters in game of thrones
which is in large part a thank you to
diana rigg's outstanding performance and
it's a shame that she passed away in
2020
a truly terrible year but going back to
her character
i just loved how much of a savage she
could be at any moment
because of that she's a very
intimidating character along with her
being very smart
this mostly culminates and all comes
together in her final scene when jaime
defeats her army
the back and forth dialogue they have
before the revelation is somewhat
entertaining in that we have a funny
roast of elena talking about jaime's
mistakes
there are always lessons in failures yes
you must be very wise by now however
jaime didn't have a lot of interesting
dialogue in the scene and was basically
just a showcase for lady olenna
which was fine for the revelation but
not necessarily for the first half where
it was more of a back and forth between
the two characters
that aspect could be better but
undeniably carried by elena spilling the
beans on joffrey's death
which warrants a fantastic reaction from
jaime
number 20 arya killing the phrase
initially i would put this moment a lot
higher given i really like arya and how
cool her power set is in game of thrones
and even the fact that this is the only
time she actually uses her power
but the double dipping nature of arya
killing the phrase in two back-to-back
scenes
feels pretty cheap what i mean by this
is that i really
enjoyed arya killing walter frey but
then reusing practically the same scene
in season 7 where arya kills the rest of
the phrase for the same effect
feels like lazy writing it's kind of
like what i highlighted earlier with
viserion and how david and dan revealed
his undead resurrection in a prior scene
if they hadn't have included the death
of walder frey in season 6
and just opened season 7 with how it
originally opens then i think it would
be infinitely better
it would be a much more surprising and
crazy moment to reveal that walter frey
was
actually arya the whole time instead of
how the scene currently is
in which the audience already knows that
it's arya this again leads to more of a
predictable outcome
when we could have had a much better
scene with crazier payoff
this is a fix that would put it closer
to the top 15 for me
instead of the 20s and again if i'm
bringing up any negative aspects for
different moments
that's just me arguing why it shouldn't
be higher on the list
number 19 the hound and arya's opening
scene in season four
to me this is a personal favorite moment
that you probably wouldn't find on any
other list for top moments
in terms of characters aryan the hounds
duo adventure
is probably peak excitement in the show
for me
their unlikely bond back and forth
hilarious banter
and their father and daughter-like
relationship is truly special
i was pondering over which scenes to
pick from their adventures
and this one has them all it has all the
humor you could ever ask for
and some of those moments have become
legendary memes like the hound wanting
to eat all the chicken
i would love to play a couple of the
short clips as an example of the humor
but the hound uttering a single line
would definitely demonetize this whole
video given that the c
word is considered a racial slur
according to youtube
but anyways even when the action starts
this is the first time in the show where
arya becomes more of her own
and helps the hound in a fight they call
back to season 2 where the lannister
soldier killed lombi with needle was
brilliant
and i'm a [ __ ] for the hound
eviscerating anyone who gets in his way
also the tension before the fight was
perfectly built up too with the hound
degrading the lannister soldier at every
chance he had
overall this is a scene i love to
rewatch and it just makes me so happy
it's a perfect end to the first episode
for season 4
and arya even got her own horsey to get
away from the hound stench
poggers number 18
jon snow's death at the time when season
5 was airing this was a crazy
cliffhanger and everyone was losing
their [ __ ]
i thought it was easily going to be one
of the best moments but man that ending
has not aged very well
the reason why it was really good
putting emphasis on was
was that it was as though the show was
returning back to its roots
and defying expectations and killing one
of the primary characters in the story
it's still a pretty great scene on its
own but the follow-up afterwards has
really diminished this moment down to
number 18 for me
the fact that jon snow's resurrection
really has no purpose whatsoever in
terms of the grand scheme of the long
night
makes this moment feel like a cheap
cliffhanger in essence
it acts as though it just mimics what
was once great about the show in terms
of killing main characters
the scene does make sense within season
5 as the consequence of jon bringing the
wildlings south of the wall
so in terms of writing it's logical for
john to die here
and is by no means forced as an isolated
moment within season 5
it's really a great ending the betrayal
of ollie and the utter and literal
heartbreak that john endures is still a
harrowing moment
the acting from both olly and john
really sells the scene as being one of
the saddest moments in the series
number 17 viserys's death scene
instead of putting in jaime pushing
brain out of the tower in here which is
pretty iconic
i instead liked viserys's death scene as
being the first primary
shocking moment that sets the tone for
game of thrones
don't get me wrong bran's fault sets a
great precedence too given how dark the
scene is
but some of the shock is lost over the
fact that bran doesn't actually die
however with viserys's death he dies in
such a gruesome and ironic way
that it shows how devious and clever the
show can be and not to mention how he
was kind of an important character given
that he was one of the last targaryens
i also genuinely just adore how well the
acting is on versailles part
and how much an entitled brat he was
this made us hate him so much and the
fact that daenerys shows no remorse
is cold as hell number 16
dany taking the unsullied this is
essentially dany's first
excellent scene where she becomes a
badass
before this she had a few moments like
standing up to her brother
and yeah that was really it besides her
getting her dragons in season 1
since season 2 was kind of a snoozefest
for her journey
however dany taking the unsullied with
force drastically changes the pace at
which her plot line was moving
and actually makes it a lot more
intriguing it feels like she's
actually progressing to becoming the
conqueror she is meant to be
besides complaining about dragons that
and the scene on its own is pretty rad
given that up until that point
she hasn't done anything truly badass to
warrant her to be a conqueror
but the scene essentially gives her a
rite of passage
she gains our respect and this shot
alone with the explosions behind her
is so memorable this is how i choose to
remember danny not the shriveling
whining mad queen that she ended up
being
number 15 the death of shea and tywin
now this is just an emotional and wild
rollercoaster of a scene
the fact that they wrote shay's death
scene in here when tyrion was expecting
to find his father was so heartbreaking
the blocking of having shae's face right
next to tyrion's face as he choked her
out
exudes a haunting layer of grief also i
love how much of a burn it is for tyrion
to find out that tywin
is having sex with a love of his life
get absolutely rolled tyrion
then after this overwhelming swell of
emotions that is the death of shay
we have tywin's confrontation the fact
that tywin plays the scene as though he
still has power over tyrion and is
confident in his ability to talk him
down
shows how stoic he is at his most
vulnerable he still comes across as an
absolute chad
and what you'll kill your own father in
the privy
then when he loses that power he goes
straight for tyrion's
jugular by denouncing him despite just
calling tyrion his son
overall a magnificent resolution to the
king's landing plotline of season four
number 14 the tower of joy for this
scene i'm going to be pairing together
the two tower of joy scenes since they
are essentially taking place back to
back
and is a direct continuation from where
the last one left off
but for the opening tower of joy scene
the fight with arthur dain was pretty
legendary
i'm a big fan of action scenes where
they pit someone against multiple
adversaries and are still able to make
it look believable like in the first ip
man then even more bonus points are
added on to the fact that this man is
dual wielding swords
what an insane mad lad that and it's
impressively variable
shot and isn't cut to [ __ ] in terms of
editing like we actually have a somewhat
long take wide shot showing the action
absolute pog the choreography more than
mixed up for the fact that someone
shouldn't really win in a fight in this
circumstance
then after that we have the reveal that
jon snow is a targaryen
so i mean a great action scene paired
with one of the biggest reveals of the
show makes this a top tier scene
number 13 the spoils of war
so visually this is a pretty sick
sequence where we finally get the
long-awaited payoff of dragon mayhem
we technically got it at the end of
season 6 but that was pretty
underwhelming given that they only
destroyed one ship
but here daenerys is rolling the
lannisters and the production value of
the battle sequence is pretty impressive
burning dozens of people at a time in a
longer take and multiple high octane
strafe runs make the sequence very fun
to watch
however the main reason why i would
write this as one of the lower battle
sequences
is that for starters the ending is
pretty much trash
jaime charging daenerys has to be one of
the stupidest moments in any battle
sequence
then his plot armor saves him when braun
comes out of left field to save the day
and somehow carries his heavy armored
ass out of the lake
there are also some other questionable
decisions made by daenerys like
destroying a lot of the supplies
not doing a strafe run down the front
line of soldiers
and how the hell she was able to get
from dragonstone to highgarden so
quickly
besides some of those stupid aspects
it's still a gripping sequence that
shows just how scary and
deadly dragons are in war
number 12 hodor
similar to the death of jon snow this
scene was spectacular when it first came
out
i literally watched it on repeat because
of how shocked i was at the fact that
bran now had the ability to time travel
that and i was kind of devastated that
my boy hoarder got killed
it was a very well executed moment and
the parallel editing of going back and
forth from brand's perspective in the
past
and to hoarder's perspective in the
present made the scene much better
then the progression of hold the door
turning into hodor was so brilliant
it kind of blew my mind that george rr
martin had this planned out or maybe he
didn't
but anyways it's still an astonishing
reveal however
i think this whole scene loses a lot of
its impact due to the sheer fact that
dumb and dumber are too brain dead to
even grasp the concept
of writing time travel in a fantasy show
then from what they said in an interview
they wanted to heavily downplay the
fantasy elements in the show
you know we tried to keep that stuff to
a minimum because
we didn't just want it to appeal to
a fantasy fan base like how can you just
introduce the craziest and coolest
concept in the show and then not use it
that's absolutely infuriating i remember
the love i had for this new ability that
bran possessed
but it slowly turned to ash in my mouth
when it became clear that bran devolved
into being a creep who stares at people
feels bad man if the show just ended
after season six then
hold the door would have been in my top
five moments for sure
this was just a bit of george r martin
shining through the veil of mediocrity
that were the later seasons
number 11 battle of the bastards
he may be upset that i'm putting this so
low at the 11th spot but
as i pointed out before in my top 25
most stupid moments
and in my analysis on season six is that
this whole sequence is really devoid of
logic
i won't get into all the aspects that
makes the sequence so stupid
but it rhymes with plot armor dumb
characters
lack of consequences and deus ex
machinas
besides those writing flaws i feel like
the battle of the bastards is able to
recover
and still make it onto my top 15. this
is hands down visually the most
breathtaking the show has ever been
though
the cinematography does everything you
want in that it gives you plenty of wide
shots to observe the action
gives you long takes and just makes you
dumbfounded by the sheer production
value
and even shots that just look like a
painting from how good the camera
composition is
it's really gorgeous while the action is
so engaging
because it's constantly evolving
throughout the battle so that it doesn't
become
dull also the pure carnage in onslaught
is crazy
horses are slamming into people there
are so many bodies out there forming
mountains
which in of itself is a bit goofy as to
how fast it happens but still
visually it's epic overall had the
writing had been on par for the other
battle episodes like blackwater and the
watchers on the wall
then the battle of the bastards would
definitely be higher on the list
number 10 hard home personally i don't
think this is as good as blackwater and
the watchers on the wall
however i enjoy it more than the other
two battle sequences because there
aren't any aspects that are overtly
devoid of logic about it
you can point to the white walker
tossing jon snow around instead of just
killing him right away as plot armor
but that still made for a cool moment
when jon snow defeated him
my only quarrel with this battle or
master rather is that there's an
abundance of fast cut and shaky action
to instill a sense of chaos you do need
these elements but i think david and dan
overuse them
it can get very tiring and visually
repetitive by relying on this type of
action
which was a major issue in the battle of
winterfell although it was much worse
there because it was also pitch black
but in hard home the amount of longer
takes with our characters is great
but i personally wanted more of that
besides that one small flaw the action
is still impressive and the sequence
sets up the night king as being one of
the most formidable antagonists in the
show
this shot of the night king raising his
arms as if he's taunting jon snow
is so visually stunning in terms of the
entire show i think this is the most
iconic
shot just a very chilling end that slows
down the pacing
to allow the audience to take in what
the hell just happened
number nine the purple wedding
this is probably the most satisfying
death in all of game of thrones
which in large part is a testament to
how much of a spectacular villain
joffrey was
jack gleason absolutely destroyed the
role and it's a shame that he quit
acting
the amount of sinisterism that was
portrayed through the character and how
unpredictable he was
was terrifying then his death as
satisfying as it was was
still able to instill a shirt of
sympathy as elena said in season 7
it looked like a terrible way to go but
man was at a crazy end to his character
that and it leads to a great performance
from cersei freaking out and accusing
tyrion
also having his death be the primary
driving force of conflict for season 4
was so much fun the aura of mystery and
the whodunit nature of his death harkens
back to what was so great about season 1
when ned was investigating the death of
jon arryn
the only small thing i partially dislike
about this scene is how long it is
but there's still a lot of great fun
little moments spread throughout
and from the overly extended length of
the scene it makes it seem as though
something bad is going to happen
so if anything it does help a bit number
eight
jamie's confession in the bath for the
dialogue alone
jaime's delivery for each line is
utterly mesmerizing
and stand by one of thousands of men
women and children turned alive would
you have done it
but you've kept your oath then i think
delivering this monologue in a state
where this character is so beat down
helps the execution he really has
nothing left at this point given he lost
his hand
and he finally spills the beans about
the truth of the mad king
not only is this perfect character
building but it also gives us a
different perspective
of the climax of robert's rebellion not
just a simple he killed the mad king ry
but a more genuine and grounded take
that paints jaime as the hero
everything he thought about jaime is now
changed thanks to this character arc
then muddying the line of good and bad
through the scenario is genius writing
i love the conundrum of being in knights
and following corrupt orders that
contradict the values of actually being
a knight
it makes for a much more real scenario
instead of the black and white good
versus evil that a lot of other fantasy
works fall into
god i love this scene it hurts so much
that david and dan take a [ __ ] on this
in season eight
innocent or otherwise to be honest i
never really cared much for them
innocent or otherwise
[Music]
number seven blackwater
this is the first time that the show
shocks the audience and not in a
traumatizing kind of way
but more in the sense of ah this
wildfire explosion is the epitome of a
chef's kiss
from the pure behemoth of delight on the
vfx side of things to even the great
reactions from different characters
to me this moment has really never been
matched in terms of the wow spectacle
factor
until say the great sept explosion here
we have a clever maneuver of strategy
thanks to tyrion and this moment was
built up to for the whole season
and this is just one moment from a whole
battle sequence
we have the epic charge to the wall
tyrion's arousing speech
and the hound cutting people to bits the
only thing that i personally don't like
from this whole sequence is how the pace
gets slowed to a crawl whenever we cut
back to cersei
and heard drunkenly talking to sansa but
overall i was heavily engaged with this
battle sequence because i genuinely
didn't know where the show would go
given how the prior season went against
expectations
that and there wasn't a true villain in
this battle since stannis and tyrion are
both protagonists and their plot lines
which helps the unpredictable nature of
how the battle turns out
number six the watchers on the wall
out of the four battle sequences i think
this one is the most well-rounded
one of the main aspects i like about
this is the fact that the entire battle
is constantly evolving in terms of
shifting perspectives
it really shakes things up instead of it
being tyrion versus stannis
in essence this creates a lot of
standout moments like tormund vs thorne
jon becoming a leader gren holding the
tunnel against the giants
ed dropping the scythe samuel actually
being useful
and other memorable moments the
choreography throughout is very
impressive because there are multiple
long takes in which people are always
fighting in the background
so it makes it feel as though this is an
epic battle where everyone is fighting
for their lives
then the ending of the sequence
surprisingly gets really emotional with
the death of egrets
the shift in music during this moment
flows expertly and i love egret's theme
it perfectly helps the shift in tone and
the final slow-mo dolly shot that pulls
back
is breathtaking hats off to the watchers
on the wall
[Music]
number five oberyn vs the mountain
i know that entire battle sequences have
a lot to offer but personally the next
five points i love to death
and i can watch them at any point in my
life and still be thoroughly entertained
oberyn vs the mountain easily qualifies
as one of those scenes because it has
everything you need in life
chad oberyn daddy tywin wicked action
lots of furious passion witty dialogue
some beautiful shots a stunning twist
and my favorite death in game of thrones
similar to the red wedding
this moment literally paralyzed me and i
looked exactly like tyrion at the end of
the episode
writing the scene to make it where
oberyn essentially wins the fight
but gets blinded by his pursuit to find
the truth about ellie martel which
results in his death is the perfect way
to properly shock your audience
it's entirely within character for
oberyn to want this information
because that's what drives his character
throughout season 4.
not some shocking moment like in season
8 when regal gets killed randomly
because that's just completely mindless
this is how you truly amaze your
audience
because we don't expect george rr martin
to be a mad light again and kill another
main character like tyrion despite him
being stayed by jaime
but yeah all the reasons i listed are
why i adore the scene and the only minor
issue i have with it
is the editing gets pretty cutty at
times but that can be forgiven
since pedro pascal is doing most of the
action
number four the courtroom trial for
tyrion
holy [ __ ] was season four a banger of a
season
i don't know whether to call this the
climax of the season because the fierce
battle of dialogue that happens between
tyrion and tywin
is so riveting the monologue that tyrion
delivers in this scene is my favorite
monologue in the show and it's so
full of emotion peter dinklage really
goes all out in the scene
and it shows a comparison to later
seasons where it doesn't really feel
like he's trying anymore because of how
bad the writing is
the courtroom trial just has so much
payoff in terms of character
interactions
so many callbacks to great moments that
come soaring back to by tearing in the
ass
and speaking of that this is probably
the best scene with a big ensemble of
characters
because they all have something of value
to contribute unlike the finale of
season 7 where a lot of the main
characters just became extras
also i always love it when the writers
give you false hope with a potential
solution with jaime agreeing to leave
the kingsguard so tyrion can live
just so that it can be squandered and
the story goes in a completely different
direction
it really adds to the bombastic twists
in the end and for that ending
i think it's one of the best line
deliveries in the show so i will let the
gods decide my
fate i demand
a trial by combat
which is then followed by a piercing
stare down between two rivals
complete perfection of a scene
number three the great sept explosion
this is literally the last time david
and dan actually try to make a good
scene
although they just have writing credits
so who knows but regardless though the
two main areas that are complete
perfection
is the music and cinematography the fact
that ramen dejawadi didn't even get an
emmy for the season is pretty wild
light of the seven is one of my favorite
tracks in the show and it perfectly
builds attention within the entire scene
the layering and introduction of
different elements in the track like
adding in the chorus when pycelles
starts to get shanked
sends chills down my spine and that goes
for every key moment in the scene where
more and more elements in the song get
added in
then when everything comes together in
the track it all explodes in a
monumentally climactic moment
this induces just as much awe as the
black water explosion did
but this time it actually kills some
bigger characters
then the scene ends in literally the
most haunting way possible
with tommen killing himself he honestly
wasn't even that likeable but his death
really sticks with you
both in a traumatizing way and in a meme
way apparently
number two the death of ned stark
this moment is basically mandatory to be
placed in the top three of any best
moments list
or at least the top five i think it's
absolutely ridiculous that watchmojo put
this moment at number 8
when they put arya killing the night
king at number 5.
this death really shapes the show as a
whole because it sets the standard of
tension and danger that surrounds every
character ned stark was the primary
protagonist of season 1
and by killing him george r martin is
essentially stating that no one
is safe also the scene is perfectly
executed
from the multiple character perspectives
the set piece of the angry crowd feeling
the adrenaline of the execution
and even in terms of editing where we
get into ned's headspace
as the sound drowns out and we visually
see close-ups showing how terrified ned
is that and i love the build up to this
scene the fact that the entire first
half plays as if ned was going to be let
go
really sells the surprise reveal because
everyone logically goes
okay this is building up to the outcome
that ned will survive
he'll be fine but nope george just has a
gift for taking the story in surprising
and fantastic directions
number one the red wedding
jesus christ can words even describe how
traumatizing this whole scene is
the pure audacity that george has to
kill not one but
two main characters in the overall story
is insane
that moment when the reigns of castinger
starts to play and lady catelyn
immediately notices that something is
wrong
it's such a great small touch it helps
the audience know something is off since
on my first watch through i didn't
really remember what the lannister theme
was
and speaking of first watch throughs i
know at least some of you watching this
made a friend or family member watch the
show
just so you can see the reaction to the
scene you sadistic animals
i'm really happy i went into the show
having not known about this twist
because it really comes out of nowhere
for the purple wedding you at least know
something bad may happen
but here we're with one of the main plot
lines
surely they won't pull another ned stark
situation right
right but yeah overall it was such a
tragic scene and the gruesome violence
really adds to the shock value that we
endured
i don't think anything can ever really
match this layer of mortifying shock
that this scene puts you in
from that alone the red wedding has my
full respect
so yeah those are my top 25 best moments
in game of thrones
there's not much need to make this video
any longer with a long conclusion
given that it's shaping up to be about
31 minutes
woe jack so much editing regardless
though
i hope you enjoyed the video and if you
have a suggestion for another ranking
video
let me know since i generally read
through most of the comments especially
if you're early
have a nice day and if you like this
video i made another ranking video on
the top 25 most stupid moments
you